the breaking news is that Turkish
officials election officials are now
officially saying that uh racet type
erdogan has won the election runoff
we're expecting him to address those
crowds that you see on your screen at
any moment this evening
so the figures that that we have this is
according to still provisional results
the official results will be declared in
a few days but the numbers are looking
like this erdogan
52.14
clicked out of glue 47.86 and
99.43 of the votes counted so that is
the very latest we're hearing some sort
of a rally cry there not sure
if president erdogan is about to speak
it looks like they're getting getting
ready to hear from him well speaking
earlier president erdogan thanked the
crowd for giving him another five years
in power
bye bye bye come on
[Applause]
thank God you have responded
the only winner today is Turkey
we have opened the doors to a new
Turkish sanctuary